hello everyone I'm Alan Saki on
welcome to simulation today we have the
three stones hey boom how's it going hey
so good to see ya Rhys is definitely one
of my favorite people we have the
pleasure of getting to talk to him about
blockchain biophysics the singularity
rhesus backgrounds awesome he is an
associate founder of singularity
University an inventor an investor so
he's very Polymathic we're gonna be
walking down a lot of different
alleyways together and very grateful to
have you on okay thank you you actually
this was really cool because when it was
like what six six or eight months ago we
were at June's event and we were
learning more about blockchain and we
were talking about it a bit and then you
kind of dropped a good amount of wisdom
on me which was you you had already kind
of found some of the weaknesses in the
technology the energy use the speed and
you were already kind of figuring out
how to potentially fix those things and
problem-solve and move forward with even
more sophisticated technology I really
appreciate that a mindset so maybe maybe
jump us into because your past is so
incredible as well maybe jump us into
some of what you've been studying what
you've been inventing over the last
couple decades and then what has come to
fruition now from those inventions and
investments
I started out studying biophysics and my
research was trying to figure out the
the chemical defect in schizophrenia and
bipolar using medical imaging techniques
and sort of nuclear medicine type
chemistry things and I was planning to
be doing that my whole life but my hobby
at the time was phone hacking and which
was something for fun
trying to play with the largest thing
people have ever invented which is the
global phone network has become the
Internet
and in the process I learned a lot about
how phone parts work and the phone
network works and ended up inventing the
what's become that blue wire that you
plug your computer into the wall with
and that became a lucrative distraction
from academia and led to a whole series
of companies doing internet plumbing
infrastructure stuff and but my core
interest has always been biophysics and
how life and biology interacts with
technology and that's led to a lot of
adventures over that time so this is so
cool so when you were initially doing
research in biophysics you were figuring
out the case of chemical defects
associated with schizophrenia and what
was what did you kind of uncover from
that first and and then what what at
what drove you you were like a tinkering
right you really wanted to tinker and
that's what drove you into this global
network of cellular and phone and
computers well the brain is is obviously
a complicated network and and it runs on
a complicated network of chemical
reactions biochemistry and there's
certain things there's a variation of
what is considered normal in brain
chemistry which leads to personality and
different kinds of what's called normal
and what's called borderline or
disordered and schizophrenia is is
really interesting thing in that it's
something that's intrinsically human and
it's considered abnormal but everybody
has some of these kind of
characteristics and and it's operating
at the core level of what is a
personality what is a mind what is a
person how do they think how do they
communicate and and so it's a very
fascinating disorder and it turns out to
be closely related to bipolar or manic
depressive type of disorders and and
that
chemistry or psychiatric drugs tend to
affect these things and then non
psychiatric drugs like hallucinogens
also tend to give people some of the
personality characteristics of
schizophrenic my exhibit and so the
early days it was thought that things
like LSD were something that was
mimicking the the what's going wrong in
schizophrenia and thought to be some
sort of closely related to how it works
and that was turned out to not be the
case that schizophrenia is still very
common worldwide and in every country
and culture 1% of the people clinically
diagnosed and and several percent of the
population being subclinical in terms of
exhibiting schizophrenic type of things
and so from biophysics or systems
biology or network theory or
biochemistry point of view this is a
really interesting problem and and I was
using biomedical techniques to try and
figure out well what in the brain and in
the metabolism and biochemistry is going
on that's different and how does that
work and so the organ of the of the
research was there's a particular carbon
network in biochemistry that regulates
things that turns things on and off
called methylation and it turns genes on
and off by methylating the DNA that
sometimes it's called epigenetics and it
regulates membranes of cells including
neurons so it regulates how rapidly
neurotransmitter receptors move across
membranes which changes how quickly
different kinds of things respond and it
also is responsible for the metabolism
of all kinds of neurotransmitters and
our chemicals and
including caffeine for example and so
the methylation of things is a way that
biochemistry turns things on or off and
the earlier research had been done of
making that particular carbon that stuck
onto things radioactive and and putting
that in people and seeing how it
eventually comes out and so it turns out
if you make the carbon of an amino acid
called methionine
radioactive that's the place that
biochemistry uses to methylate things
with and eventually some of that carbon
comes out in the breath as co2 and the
if you make that carbon radioactive you
can measure it coming out in the breath
and it turns out in a normal person that
comes out at one kind of rate over hours
but a nice kid say phrenic person it
comes out much faster and and and it and
oddly enough in a bipolar person it
comes out halfway in between normal and
schizophrenic and so the step from going
from this methionine through all the
chemical reactions into eventually co2
there's maybe 50 steps in that process
in biochemistry and so putting it in
this way and watching it come out that
way is different in these different
populations so the project was figure
out well what step or why is it
different maybe there's some enzyme
deficiency or some genetic deficiency
that explains that and and so the
project was was making various versions
of this carbon and putting it in people
so carbon 13 which you can measure
magnetically and carbon 14 which is a
long slow mild radioactivity and then
carbon 11 which is a short half-life
version of carbon that that
a half-life of only 20 minutes and it
emits a positron and this can be used
traced using brain imaging techniques
that are like cat scans and MRIs but are
called PET scans for positron emission
tomography and so with pet you can tell
where something is and and how it comes
and goes and then with carbon-13 in
magnetic fields you can tell what
chemical form it's in and carbon-14 you
can leisurely detect it coming out in
the in the breath and the blood and and
different metabolites of it so using a
combination of these different forms of
carbon to follow this network of
biochemistry and follow this metabolism
over time the goal was to figure out
what's going on and obviously it's a
really complicated project and I was
planning to spend a long time on it I
just been more or less 10 years on it
and it it turns out that schizophrenia
and bipolar is very complicated dynamic
and and situation and and the genetic
studies of schizophrenia have sort of
indicators maybe 50 genes that are
related to this so it's probably not one
genetic defect in one biochemical enzyme
or something like that it's a much more
complicated situation that is not only
just the metabolism but it's also like
social cues and environmental cues and
and so it's it's a fascinating thing
about what it is to be a human and how
human psyche works and how the mind
works and how about chemistry works and
how social networks work you know and
you said methylation that's also
something that you were teaching me
about recently
so how gene causing genes to turn on or
off and so then with your study of
schizophrenia and how you gave that
really interesting example about when
the carbon and
bipolar as well there come the carbon
comes out at different times in the
breath different rates so over a couple
hours of time maybe a couple percent of
the carbon that was on an amino acid a
part of a protein called Matheny will
come out in the breath but 90% of it is
stuck on two membranes and jeans and and
other molecules that don't come out in
the breath and so that is a like a
really highly conserved part of genetics
not just in humans but in most
biochemical species and it's used for a
lot of really important things as I said
turning things on or off and so like a
common one is genes where it'd be for
when we hit puberty right we have the
genes that turn on for our growth spurt
or for our actual reproductive organs
things like that yeah yeah so as as an
organism develops it has genes to say
grow a body now grow teeth now grow
different sorts of things and once those
are grown the those genes that are doing
that need to stop this thought and one
of the mechanisms that they're stopped
is as a carbon is stuck on that gene and
the machinery that reads the gene says
oh well this one has turned off so keep
going and so and then other genes that
say start puberty now or start menopause
now or start aggression now get your nun
and so these turning genes on and off is
has a regulatory network and that's
called methylation and well the
percentage of your genome that's
methylated is actually a really good
measure called the Horvath clock one of
the best measures of how old you are and
how long you have to live maybe explain
horvath clock a little bit more and so
that's a measure of
what percentage of your DNA or what
percentage of your genes have been
methylated meaning it's it's a regular
DNA plus an extra carbon stuck on there
and that carbon is like a light switch
that they replicating and and metabolism
enzymes that run along the DNA like a
train on tracks comes to that and either
works or it or it doesn't work and so
when you stick a methyl on something the
machinery passes it by and it's
basically turned off and in some cases
the methylation turns it on but that's
the more kind when too many of the genes
become turned off that is when pathology
or disease kicks it well the opposite
almost there where you have genes that
say grow a tooth here and now and and
that's really important to have teeth
and and the teeth grow in the early
stages of development the methylation
stops working well well and so some
cancers for example are immortal and
they're growing at the wrong time and
they're especially in the wrong genes in
the wrong place at the wrong time and so
for example some tumors will actually
grow things like hair or grow teeth in
in your liver yeah and you don't want to
fly liver and that's those are genes
being expressed that have normally been
turned off everywhere else in the body
but in cancer mutation they accidentally
get turned back on yeah okay so so the
pathology can come on from either Oh
methylation not working or from it
actually from it not working and then
the process that is not supposed to
occur occurs or from it not working in
the process that was supposed to occur
did not occur right so what are those
two powers but these things are time
sort of biological clock says to at what
time should you go into breeding
characteristics where you you shouldn't
be before and you shouldn't be after and
these things are genes turning on and
off and complicated part of life
methylation is another really cool thing
that you've been teaching about I really
find that interesting and I'm glad that
your research was in that and you get
these little insights from more research
into the field and into things like
schizophrenia and so okay so now walk us
down a little bit of this whole you know
networks and communication and Internet
so how did you realize that we needed to
be connected to like the cat5 how did
you how did you come up with this yeah
so it's so biochemistry is a network and
so is the brain and so is metabolism and
and it changes over time which is life
and and birth and aging and and death
and across species and it's not just in
humans it's the same in plants and
animals and microbes of various kinds
and so these are complicated networks of
many different factors that change over
time and so is the internet and so or is
the phone network and so it's traffic
and so is social networks and so is a
food web and and the way culture works
in the way information flows through
culture like news and memes and and
things and these things get turned on
and off and they work in a network
effect type way and so this is all areas
that I was Eddie you just went yeah you
just connected how genetics and
methylation works to how the cultural
programming works because there are
certain memes that turn on and then they
turn off yeah and that's just really
fascinating how you can make that
connection
yeah and it's a decentralized
distributed system so life is a
decentralized system there isn't like a
president of life or a central computer
of life or a central database of genes
they're distributed and they operate
independently
but as part of a network and the
networks have dynamics and so these are
are very similar kinds of dynamics
whether it's a news network or a food
network or yeah biochemical network and
maybe if we zoom out far enough and we
look at the pale blue dot then maybe it
can look like a centralized entity well
that assumes that it's the biochemical
Network life only exists on the pale
blue dot and yeah correct and then all
indications are no it's not that way
yeah so that that was that was really
good so yeah I keep keep wandering us
down this whole understanding of how the
life is also like a network kind of like
biology isn't yeah well as a person each
of us thinks about how well I am an
individual person and everything
revolves around me but objectively a
person is part of a complex network
there's their family there's the food
that they eat there's the information
that they transact and so a person is is
really a node on a network and not
necessarily a isolated thing in and of
themselves and so the how the network
affects each of us and how we affect the
network is kind of a nuanced problem
that is kind of intuitive to even notice
as an individual person can we say that
we're both individualistic in our
ability to find fulfilment to find
meaning in life and you know build that
thing into the world but we're also
collective in the sense that we are node
on the network and I would say yes
that's true but it's not half half it's
more like 99% Network 1% so and that
like if we don't have food we're not as
self very long and and the food you have
to eat life to live as much as the
vegetarians who think they don't eat
life but they do eat life and the only
in life yeah plant life and you can
maybe make something like Soylent that
is
you know ingredients of life but most of
them come from life yeah and so the a
person and the metabolism of a person or
a plant or whatever is very dependent on
the nutrients that that come from other
life forms and so life is really a
network and not individuals that's a
really eager dwarfing sort of
understanding of reality because we are
just a little node on the network of
food and a family and work and culture
and social media and even your
healthcare you're educating you're just
a little note on the network on all
these different networks that are then
all intertwined into a massive web and
so what what else has that realization
taught you over over the over the years
well things like ego and consciousness
and perhaps freewill are illusions that
are important behaviorally but they're
actually counterproductive in terms of
being a citizen of a network and
ecosystem is it fair to say that we need
a little bit of ego to make sure that we
might we don't get maybe hurt or
something that we can maybe ensure that
we thrive so an example is maybe we need
to be very aware of our own safety when
we're walking somewhere that might be
unsafe or maybe would that mean that we
need a little bit more ego during that
time to make sure that we are analyzing
our environment and because the network
might not keep us safe in that region
sure well so if you think about
developing as a as a person we start out
as an infant that more or less has no
noticeable ego and is very dependent on
the mother and the family and the food
supply and
and that not really aware of themselves
being separate from other so self and
and other are all one a sort of a non
dualistic way as an infant and an infant
doesn't necessarily have an ego or even
a free will and that the the mother
decides when it's time to eat or or not
and manages safety and and other things
sort of an all-powerful all-knowing God
like being in the life of an infant and
and as as we develop and grow we mature
to feed ourselves and and mobilize
ourselves and then when puberty kicks in
the the mode of the hormone only driven
motivation to breed has a sort of look
elsewhere from the family and siblings
and relatives to to find a suitable
breeding partner and that is obviously
best if it's not Umbria noir in the same
genetic pool and so one of the
manifestations is developing
independence and an ego that says I'm
separate from you or I'm separate from
my mother from my family and Freud and
Jung and all kinds of psychological
analyst if I've thought about this in
great detail but the basic is as as
people or other species move to breeding
age they separate from their biological
family and they go looking for suitable
differentiated breeding partners and
that's driven by hormones which drive
ego which drive dominant behavior which
drive
mate seeking behavior and separation and
and that kind of thing which is
something that that comes on about
puberty time maximizes our peak breeding
and fertility time but then diminishes
later in life yes and and that more or
less tracks how ego goes and that it's
something that is minimal early in life
and later in life but it is sort of
maximal during peak fertility time and
so that's something that well some
practices like Buddhism and meditation
are how do you reduce the ego and how do
you eliminate the effects of this
personality characteristic that isn't in
young people and isn't in older people
but it is in sort of the middle range of
life that tends to be driven by hormones
to be driven to psychological things
that we might call ego as one or
aggression is another that might
actually not be so good for life and so
developing practices of how to use
suppress that and reduce that leads to
happier lives yeah exactly that was so
well explained I've been able to find
that these 10-day meditation retreats do
that for me or maybe a little bit of
psilocybin or LSD or other things can
really do that for you just wharfing of
this ego so you you kind of painted it
out really well that when the child is
but made into the world that the child
is the parent as the god to the child
takes really all responsibility for it
so the ego isn't really there would you
would you say that consciousness is
developing in the womb or a
consciousness when this when is it to a
child when is the being conscious well
so consciousness is a fascinating topic
and and and nobody is really quite sure
what it is or how it works
and the some of the most interesting
thinking about it in my opinion are
people like - noni or others that that
have we have different subsystems that
fuse together functionally to be
consciousness and there's a saying I
think from Bateson as where is the edge
of a person they're of a man and is it
our body or is it our environment and so
they use the example of where is the
edge of a man with an axe is it at the
hand is it the axe is it the blade of
the axe is where the axe could strike is
it where he could run with that so that
what defines a person isn't just their
skin it's like their sphere of influence
and consciousness more or less extends
to that sphere of influence it's not
just well if something is outside of my
skin it doesn't mean I'm not conscious
of it or it doesn't mean that it's not
part of my being and so the it's
subsystems of my hand and my arm and my
nerves and the part of my brain that
those are connected to are fused into
the overall the other side and and the
other subsystems that are me to be my
consciousness which isn't limited to my
body and that this extends not just
within a person their right hemisphere
and left hemisphere forming one
consciousness but it extends
interpersonally so when you have friends
and associates and and relationships you
form a joint consciousness with them so
like a couple who knows each other well
or a parent-child family dynamic they
collectively decide when were tired or
when we're hungry and when we should eat
and where we should sleep and and these
things are collective consciousness that
extends obviously between individuals
and family units but into tribes and
cultures and societies in that there's
sort of a national consciousness or a
corporate consciousness or
community or religious consciousness
that is mate made up of the amalgam of
the many different parts subsystems and
experiments of like lobotomy cutting the
right and left hemisphere still seems to
have a consciousness but each side has a
sub consciousness that are no longer
connected as well and not communicating
as well so that if one hand is solving a
puzzle that it can see controlled by one
hemisphere and the other hemisphere can
see it too and and knows how to solve
that problem the the person will
actually grab the arm and help solve the
problem across the two hemispheres that
are normally connected internally but if
they're not connected internally
connected externally so when you're
somewhat separated from people you know
well you might text them a message
saying well here's how you solved that
problem and that's a indirect way to
work as a consciously collective unit
yes in a sense and and that that seems
again to play into what you were
discussing earlier which was the whole
culture acting as a network human groups
acting as a network very similar to how
systems biology does so I really find a
fascinating that we're continuously
coming back to understanding life in
this perspective of you are both a
conscious being but you are also very
frequently immersed into a collective
conscious being with other people and
that changes dynamics so much from an
individual to a group and and and just
to be aware of that process is very
important so okay so you said
consciousness and freewill and ego
illusions well so locally those things
feel very real but from a distance like
the pale blue dot or even across the
room they may are localized like you're
like if you have a banana on the table
and you go I
and eat that that it feels locally to be
free will and a conscious act yes but
you know an observer observing from
across the room whether you're a monkey
or a humans would say oh well that
monkeys probably hungry so I can eat
that banana look it did you know spy
ology that's not free will and so the
it's a matter of perspective yeah I see
what you're saying okay so so the
perspective changes because it's low
because it's low when you're looking at
it localized through that kind of the
whole excel of Cystic perspective when
you're looking at it from behind your
own eyes it looks like and feels like
you have free will but from an observers
perspective it doesn't look like oh it's
just biology telling that human to
further heart to beat that hundred
thousand times in the day or for them
yeah believe this second you and them to
take a breath right now but could live
without doing those things so that's why
yeah well I and so researchers who study
this like more and surf at Northwestern
for example who has electrodes in
people's brains while they're waiting
surgery for something else that tracks
how ideas are formed and how recognition
is forming how decisions are made finds
that that subsystems of the brain decide
they're going to do something before you
become conscious of it yes and so the
like my eyes are telling my brain to
evaluate my hunger before I even
realized that there's a banana there and
that I should eat it you know and so the
these kind of things appear to be well
like I'm deciding to do that where your
brains already decided long before that
it's going to do that and then your
consciousness is actually rationalizing
the collective behavior and sort of the
same way as a spokesperson for a family
or community will rationalize well this
is what our government did and this is
why where the decision to do it happen
yeah before and by other subsystems this
reminds me a lot of behave Robert
Sapolsky book there's how it goes back
at an evolution for billions years prior
to actual the actions that I do to eat
the actual banana the the effort that
goes into the stomach communicating with
the brain by analyzing the last day when
was the last time you ate how many
nutrients will you earn from that banana
how difficult it is to get that banana
how much does the banana cost there's so
many variables that go into this
I actually I want a loop Ron and Ron
what do you think about
about consciousness and free will and
all of that being a illusion or I agree
with Reese halfway even why elaborate
well we we are the master of our own
destiny no what do you think Reese I
don't think we decide when we're gonna
have puberty or very often when we're
gonna die or or when we're going to find
food that some of these things happen
and then we rationalize of oh I hunted
that banana and I found it and so I'm a
great hunter of bananas what about the
whole destiny
though what about like what Reese Jones
impact is in the world do you get to
decide that because one day you can wake
up and decide that you want to focus on
biophysics the next thing you can wake
over decide you wanna focus on
blockchain so you can choose to do a
whole year of one of those things can't
you sure and so Sapolsky would say it's
all biology that there isn't a free will
and that and other people would say well
free will is a really important part of
being human and that it's it's
everything that we do and so in physics
there's there's this concept of a local
like the speed of light and time happen
or a local to an observer
and that I would say free will maybe or
what appears to be free well maybe
similar we're supposed to would say it's
all biology and an another way to look
at it is me deciding to touch this cup
well that's a limited free will and it
locally appears to be free well and it
doesn't seem to be motivated by biology
yeah excepting communicating point and
and that that is something that is sort
of like a local phenomena like the time
or speed of light local to me appears to
be this but from a distance and again a
matter of perspective it may not be as
obvious do you think we are masters of
our own destiny only to a limited extent
yeah
rania you ever know to a limited extent
we also were a machine in ourselves with
a stronger a higher power calling the
shot making stuff happen using us beat
puppets yeah we don't decide when and
where we're born we don't necessarily
decide when and where we die we don't
necessarily decide a lot of the things
that happen in the arc of our life and
and so those things are not part of our
consciousness and they're not even in
our control or even awareness per se and
in the middle range sure that we might
decide what to do apparently of our own
volition yeah without any influence of
something in the network or in ourselves
but it's I think the 99% of that may be
our own volition and freewill is 1%
opening there is a percentage that it if
you think about we're a biochemical
network that is you know asking for
vitamin a and and
were part of a food network that over
that you know meat has that and then
we're part of an ecosystem that has its
own dynamics and so we're in you know
biochemical network in an food network
in an ecosystem network so a network of
networks which is a and the
manifestation is is between the networks
and so that's literally an internet work
and where's the internet and so our
participation in these network of
networks is as as a node maybe but not
as a controlling system yeah yeah
exactly
okay so that's again the 99 to 1 percent
your consciousness your ability to take
control of what you're actually doing
within the network is only a very very
small percentage versus what your role
is within the network as the node is
that's what the 99% is very similar to
your yeah free will and conscious
control as well you think you were
saying you're your birth and your death
and when your genes methylate and when
you get to choose if you want a salad or
a burger and but but your consciousness
says I'm gonna get a burger
because whatever rationalization you
have and the however like your decision
to do that may be motivated by other
things like not only your own
biochemistry but the microbes in in your
intestine you may not have had a burger
for a month it really wants and and the
family of microbes that came from
burgers that are inside of you are
subtly persuading you to get another
burger to repopulate that family with
the things that they want and and so in
some ways were like these microbes are
like the jelly and a jelly doughnut and
and the person is just carrying them
around and keeping them comfortable and
they may be saying I want a salad or I
want a burger sound
to the car and and the consciousness is
tricked into thinking I'm gonna go get a
salad or I mean that does feel like what
it is sometimes it's fascinating yeah it
is and this family of microbes that that
lives within us is that is that is it
true that there's just vastly more
microbial cells within our gut than
there are even human cells yeah there's
more microbial cells in US and on us on
our skin and so forth than human cells
but those microbes have different DNA
and different genes and so there's
actually vastly more genes that are
non-human than in our human you know in
an adult yeah and then so then the way
that they're communicating with us and
directing the way that we live is
something that we don't even really
understand that well yet and that we're
trying to understand better because
apparently it even influences our what
we think are our conscious decisions but
and our our relationship decisions where
we're eating the same food and and in a
business decision or a social dynamic
where you're breaking bread with
somebody to share the same food to
populate like crossbreed the same
microbes and motivations internally so
you're more likely to be in alignment
after you've shared food with other
individuals than it than before yes yes
it's also very good
so the oxytocin the connection the trust
that you'll have with the person once
you've broken bread with them
oxytocin is a really interesting topic
and that it's something that's
stimulated by sort of maternal behavior
and mating behaviors and things like
that that increases the bonding between
individuals like touch and it's a and it
strengthens the local bonds but some
evidence like Sapolsky talks about this
and Ann Lewis and others that it may be
strengthens the local connections but it
increases the adversarial distances so
it's it's both makes you more tribal
it's both well yeah so at a tribal level
so like the US and them and the like our
team their team but even in a
relationship it's like oh well this
person like jealousy is also a function
of oxytocin where the you know where
somebody wants to be in close coupling
with a partner that's sort of an
oxytocin type maintain relationship but
that increases the adversarial
relationship with other partnership
threats so the it sort of increases the
the jealousy of well that person might
harm our relationship so I'll push them
away while I'm trying to get closer to
this person so it cuts both ways anyway
and yeah yeah and we've been talking so
much about how things work as systems
having that general understanding is so
important we were just yesterday talking
about the importance of having an
understanding of history the present and
the future
because then one can look back 50 years
at suffrage and
segregation and today if anyone's
talking about women suffered her
segregation in a way that's in favor of
those things then they're either they
could make headline news and so just to
have that analysis of where we've gone
and how we've gotten there and where we
are similarly to what I'm thinking for
the next 50 years for people to have you
know we're talking about clean meat in
the future we're looking back 50 years
it'll be like how the hell did we why
did we do that to so many animals why
are we doing it that way it's so great
to have the systems that we have now and
I think that same thing we'll go for an
overall ability to conceptualize systems
level thinking whether it be within the
body and the biology whether it be
through consciousness and collective
consciousness through the culture what
we're doing as a culture to look back
hopefully 50 years from now we'll look
back and we'll say how were we not
educating kids every kid to have a
general understanding of what is going
on inside of themselves how they
interplay with the world around them how
they're just another node in the
interplay of what's going on in the
network so do you maybe have
recommendations for parents to best help
their children understand these things
at young ages well I think a non dualist
perspective were we're all connected
we're all part of the same thing there
isn't really an other or them or they
it's sort of part of us as a including
plants and animals not not just people
and that that of course we need to eat
plants and animals if you choose to live
but the they in turn need to get
resources and so it's a part of a system
that if you're aware of it to some
extent
I think you can be happier in life and
that there in a sense then there aren't
adversaries
except temporary or local or illusional
adversaries but the we're all part of
one system yeah that right there's but
that's a huge point for for what we're
trying to help have conversations about
on simulation is how how do we end up
building a better future together and I
think you nailed it one of the things
that parents can help young kids learn
is that a non-dualistic perspective
about life about a very inclusive a very
kind of collective we are one
perspective about network theory and
understanding how systems interplay with
one another but so many people get
scared by collectivism and so many
people get scared by the issues that
have occurred in the past with with
thoughts schools of thought like that
they're scared of socialism or communism
that they they relate that with
collectivism there it's almost it's
almost like a PTSD in a sense rather
than thinking about it in a five-year or
ten-year or twenty or what what could
collectivism look like where there is so
much more access to clean food and clean
water and shelter and education and
healthcare across the world how could
how could we grow as an organism as that
pale blue dot in the cosmos well well if
you think about it in a million year
timeframe as opposed to five year time
frame that like we're part of an
ecosystem and we were a million years
ago and and hopefully we will be a
million years from now and some of these
terms are ideological terms that people
trying to create a pure ideology based
on an idea that isn't completely thought
out exactly yeah
and so collectivism God
is one of those ideological terms it's
just it's not fully mapped out or
thought-out in its fullest most powerful
extent yet and like where does the food
come from where does the waste go how
does a yeah operate more efficiently
yeah where does the energy come from
where does the energy go where does how
do we provide health access the
healthcare access to people without
breaking the bank or making it seem like
it's complete welfare system all these
kind of questions and this is why we
have these conversations on simulation
because it's we'd get so frequently
stuck in a binary yes or no to questions
but they're so complicated they're so
nuanced and they're so fun to unpack in
all of their details because then you
lead to better understandings of like
you said a million year timescale or
even something less scary is like what
long now foundation 10,000 year
timescale because we're not gonna
survive by having egos go through the
roof I always use this analogy and I'm
interested to hear what your thoughts
are on this analogy but very we were
talking about this with Jordan Peterson
as well very competent people understand
that helping people brings them more
meaning and fulfillment in life and it
almost it almost doesn't make sense to
me why one would purchase a third yacht
instead of hire 50 people to solve a
problem in the world what do you what do
you think about that well part of that
is a fear driven by fear and fear is
largely a dualistic concept that there's
some something other that you're afraid
of yes
and a third yacht might be that your to
existing yachts aren't good enough to
overcome your fear of being viewed as
not good enough and so you need to
accumulate these things to to find
acceptance in the network and that you
know does the rest of the network value
50 people solving a problem or did they
value you and and then what you're
motivated to do is you know are you
helping the network in general or are
you trying to manage your fear you know
exactly I just if the network if all the
other nodes were to come to a consensus
about hiring 50 people to solve a
problem is by far the better decision
well it depends on how you evaluate that
the the 50 people and the other 50
people who have a lottery of being one
of those 50 people would say oh by far
that's the better choice but the yacht
builder in the yacht seller would say no
no you should do the yeah yeah and so
there's people that work for that
company yeah build that as well and
those materials it's still an economic
stimulus and whatnot so you have so it
doing things exactly the same for all
people isn't necessarily the optimum
solution so it wouldn't be wouldn't be a
got it so it wouldn't be like a
consensus around there being one option
that's absolutely better it'd be like
here's all the options make your
decision but see what that also doesn't
seem like it it's optimal either you
can't have an economic system and
financial markets on a finite planet
that just have all these options and say
do whatever you want to do well hidden
in that sentence is the term finite
planet and and that
I mean this planet it if you just look
at solar energy isn't finite that the
the resources that are on this planet
are coming from somewhere else and so
there's a flow of energy in there's a
radiation of heat out there's some of
that Energy's turned into food and
people and rockets and stuff and so it's
it's a it's an open system and it's not
finite in that it's a you know locally
infinite solar system and galaxies and
so forth so it's part of a larger whole
as opposed to being the whole in and of
itself so besides the star powering the
earth what else provides infinite
resources well the so our perspective
there's a saying that like the the Stone
Age didn't end because of the lack of
stones in that in that it's a perception
of what is the necessary ingredients and
and like the oil age is probably not
going to end because of the lack of oil
is that people find alternatives that
are better correct and and so the in
infinite infinity of it is is the
alternatives that have yet to be
discovered or yet - or maybe they're
very obvious right in front of us but
they're yet to be noticed yes correct
and so that that's indicative of overall
progress from from Stone Age Bronze Age
etc similarly from oil to solar etc oh
great but should there be some sort of
an ethical consideration around
financial markets or even an ethical
consideration around business in general
because a lot of Millennials and a lot
of Gen Z kids are starting to vote with
their money in the direction of
sustainability in the direction of
philanthropy in the direction of
altruism businesses that focus on those
things well to some extent the
like these kind of things have to emerge
they have to evolve and they're all each
or subject to natural selection and so
the variations of conduct and behavior
the the traits that that people exhibit
will either be selected for or against
in the ecosystem that they're exhibited
and so if if people are like doing
things in an ecologically sustainable
way is not a new concept
you know native peoples almost
everywhere in the world were more or
less in homeostasis harmony with their
environment and so this concept of
saying well consumerism and pollution
and waste and so forth we need to fix
that well that's sort of a temporary
aberration and and it happens at all
kinds of different scales like you know
people don't defecate in their own bed
in their own house so that they because
the people who do got disease and got
selected against yeah and so that kind
of thing isn't because a government or a
tribe said do this or don't do that I
mean that is something that communicates
their survival information and and
that's why religions succeed still
because they package the the infinite
realm of choices into a recommended set
that you don't have to figure out why
those are recommended and the others are
not you can just on faith say well this
is a recommended set that I can trust
there's been debugged for a long time
and so having fish on Friday that's the
rule or you could say well you know
maybe that makes me have a diversified
diet and makes me have trading
relationships with people in a different
environmental system so if there is a
change in the climate and our desert
food doesn't work our fishing friends
will be able to feed us and the fishing
people you know that there's a red tide
and we can't eat the fish then our land
friends will be able to sew so you can
analyze a particular meme or our trait
that comes from a religion or a way of
thinking and trying to rationalize why
it works but you can also say well this
one has survived for thousands of years
and these different kinds of communities
and it evidently does work and and just
take it on faith and say well if I do
that then life will be easier so the top
down sort of government and legislation
does not work for enabling markets and
people to make decisions and slowly come
up with through evolution through
mimetics the what ends up being the
prevailing outcome well there's a role
for that like if you were to put two
political equally Democratic vote like
should we build a sewer treatment plant
should we build a highway system should
we have air traffic control should we do
some of these things that require kind
of a centralized top-down type of
decision-making and resource allocation
like the average voter might say no we
don't need a new freeway and the other
side of the world or country and and so
their vote on on that decision might not
be the best overall choice the best
overall vote and so having a
representative democracy where the local
people who understand what the traffic
is in that area say well we need this
and the people who don't really
understand what the dynamics are they
think you know their issue is more
important then they each you know
communicate that to a representative
that then communicates that to a
distributed but somewhat centralized
decision-making and and so that's proven
to be effective and more effective than
a theoretical ideological pure one for
one democracy yeah and modernizing
tomorrow
see will take its route kind of as we
went over the last over 200 years and
figuring out how to add amendments and
modernize it I think we'll see a little
bit more of that in the next couple
decades as well especially with the
proliferation of technology what's
actually gonna happen to government into
democracy will be very very interesting
[Music]
okay I want to touch on this at least
for a little bit as we get to the
conversation about a singularity maybe
we touch on technologies that are
enabling such a process so one of the
favorites that that you and I are both
very familiar with is blockchain
technology and so having a digital
ledger
that's decentralized be in be in use for
so many different applications of life
such as currency in the way we exchange
value such as even potentially voting
systems all this good stuff what are
your thoughts about the industry and
what are your thoughts about where it's
gonna go well so we're very familiar
with with command and control
centralized government systems and and
representative democracies and that kind
of thing which is a way of organizing a
tribe or a nation or religion or that
kind of meta structure and and I sort of
looked to genetics and biochemistry and
life and biology is not centralized it's
it's fully decentralized as fully
distributed it's peer to peer and so if
you were to make a list of what are the
characteristics of blockchain and and
Bitcoin and and these things the that
they're decentralized that they're
immutable that they're distributed would
that those things that you would
describe it coin are the same as
describing biology yeah and and biology
was not immutable it's mutable but it
also is subject to Darwinian natural
selection and so those random species
and choices either they survive or they
don't based on their characteristics and
and that can be different in different
parts of the world and different
ecosystems and so blockchains there's
not one of them there's many different
kinds of block chains and and to me
those are like different species of
creatures and so these different species
whether they aetherium blockchain or the
bitcoin blockchain survives or goes
extinct and thrives our or is in a niche
will be a function of not just its
characteristics but how those
characteristics map to the ecosystem
that it's in and so if a distributed
system like biology in life functions in
a in a network type way so will these
block chains and distributed information
flows and so in both cases for me it's
information flow across the network and
so whether a gene or a trait propagates
through many species of life would be
the same as as through different kinds
of digital block chains and and
distributed ledger systems in that
they're a flow of information and there
are things that have evolved over
billions of years and in the flow of
information in life which is carried by
genetics and and and DNA and and the
coding and metabolism and sort of the
biochemical ecosystem those that same
dynamic will likely happen if the flow
of digital information and and that's
not just blockchain in isolation it's
how does digital information flow across
the internet across the world not not
just in how do I get a you know a bit
from me to you well that's that's the
Internet Protocol that's the
transmission control protocol and then
how do you pass it on to the next person
well that's the intern
protocol so there we have tcp/ip and
then there's file transfer protocols and
and verification and so forth and and
blockchain has evolved out of that in
that it's another layer of protocol on
the Internet of how do I give something
to you and and that you then have it and
I no longer have it and that it's a
ledger yeah yeah and that and that's a
consensus ledger which is the mechanism
that is used to to keep a record of me
giving it up and you getting it rather
than a centralized well and so and so
historically that's been done by for
example banks that that I tell the bank
I'm gonna give it to you the bank says
okay it's off your Ledger's on yours and
if there's a dispute we can both go to
the bank and say well what happened
and so blockchain takes that and
distributes it in a similar way that
genetics works that the record of when I
transferred something from me to you is
it's held not just by one bank but by
millions of different banks if you will
and those would be nodes on the
blockchain that are recording each
transaction and and that's a distributed
system just like biology and biology
never had a ledger of the last four
billion years well so it so DNA genetic
heritage is kind of a ledger of the
different genes and specie of a species
and and all of its ancestors that all
the different species are basically
cousins of each other and that so we're
related to mushrooms and trees and fish
and so forth
but we don't know those 90 million
species that have died well that's right
but there is trace of them in our
genetic trace of them yeah and so one of
the problems with with bitcoins
blockchain for example is that it takes
a lot of energy to propagate to
replicate so it takes a lot of energy to
stay alive and species that take a lot
of energy to stay
I've gone extinct and so one of the
things the characteristics of blockchain
bitcoins blockchain is that it uses a
mechanism proof of work that that
requires a lot of energy to replicate
itself so saying I need many hamburgers
to to reproduce and and that has a side
effect in that there's a lot of that
energy is wasted and so if it could be
more efficient it would be more likely
to survive in longer over a millions of
years and the and then the other thing
that is different in biology is that
biology doesn't keep a record of every
single transaction and that there is
some representation of dinosaurs and
clams and and fungi in our DNA but the
not a complete record of all of
everything that happened and so bitcoins
blockchain at the moment keeps a
complete record in a very energy
inefficient way and those are kind of
two strikes against it for long term
survival and evolutionists decided well
like which transactions do you keep on
the ledger and which ones you just
ignore or forget or pass off to another
blockchain that can process them faster
well so you could cross this faster but
you have to you know like if somebody
bought a pizza 2,000 years ago with the
blockchain is it really important to
remember that transaction probably not
and so the the the architecture of
remembering every transaction may be
over weighted and and it and like an
obese algorithm yeah that may have a
lower chance of survival than one that
forgets correct exactly and so do you
think that's part of our future is a
blockchain that forgets yeah I well so I
think that blockchain is like genetics
it's like DNA it's like species so each
different kind of blockchain is like a
different species that has like summer
turtles in summer rabbit
and and those have different
characteristics and one of the other
might win the race they might both
finish yeah what might be faster the
other might be more reliable and and so
what happened in genetics is there were
a small relatively small number of
species and the there was an innovation
in species like sensors like eyes
evolved and there was changes in the
climate and those led to Cambrian
explosion it was called where there was
three and a half million new species
emerge very quickly and so we may be in
the pre Cambrian explosion era of block
chain distributed systems that is a
really good way in all likelihood there
will be millions not exactly not kin and
then at the and then towards the end
there will be a human race so ba of the
technology as well as in there might
only be one or two or three in use that
are very similar to currency as well
when currency was birth so he was like a
Cambrian explosion in terms of
currencies and now there's one per
country pretty much so we might see
something similar convergence into the
most popular block chains it's the ones
that provide the most utility for humans
yeah and and there are plenty of niche
species that you know this one lives
under deep-sea volcanic vents yeah and
and where it's the only one that can
live there yeah and the others it's
incredible yeah and so it's having a
human's view themselves as the dominant
species but in terms of a number of
individuals or weight of living matter
or number of species humans are a tiny
fraction of life on this planet and that
microbes make up most of it and and
Dawkins would say well humans you know
the microbes told evolution to make
something to carry them around and and
so we're you know we evolved as
transportation for microbes and
Bruce on their say that like we're a
species that or these complex species
have emerged on earth for now but mostly
it was microbes that still mostly is
microbes in the future likely will be
microbes and these complicated
human-like things are temporary mm-hmm
yeah okay so on our way to the
convergence of all these technologies do
you think that artificial intelligence
what do you think about genetic
engineering neural laces what do you
think about space colonization and where
we stand
geopolitically as we compete with other
countries to be the first to come up
with these technologies what do you
think about that well it's quite a list
you gave I'm in favor of all those
things yes likewise like genetic
engineering and robotics yeah yeah in
space likewise but how do you how do you
feel about the the the sort of
geopolitical kind of stressors that
we're sort of facing with with certain
countries that are wanting to there's so
many existential threats are now looming
because of the advances in these
technologies even though we are very in
favor of them were in favor of them and
very benevolent and and prosperous ways
not and we're not in favor of the ones
that extinct the species so well I think
people are afraid of new things
generally and and that these you know
genetics robotics nanotech AI type of
technologies they can be good or they
can be bad just like fire yeah and that
you know fire it can burn you can burn
down your whole village but it also
something you can cook with and you can
transport yourself with and be warm and
so forth so bad things will happen with
any new technology
but it also can be directed largely into
good useful purposes do you have a
general principle or two that you abide
by when it comes to developing new
technology into the world because things
like running the artificial intelligence
are running the edited genes on a
network that is closed might be ideal
yeah so what do you have something like
that well proceed with with some caution
and care that until you know whether
this fire will burn down a village it's
best to experiment with it in a
fireplace a place for experimenting with
fire and so these things once they
become kind of evident in the culture
they will evolve and persist regardless
of what a government or society says to
do with them and that Kevin Kelley has
this concept of the Technium which is
like technology evolving complexity and
and biology or humans evolving
complexity and that they're both
happening napped by natural evolution
yeah and that can't necessarily be
stopped and can be used for good yeah
okay I I appreciate you're very
optimistic perspective on it I also
carry a very optimistic perspective on
it I really try and also be realistic
and that's what we do on simulation is
we ask about a lot of realistic
scenarios that are sort of looming over
our heads with things like wealth
inequality with these technologies as
well do you have any thoughts around
eight people having as much wealth right
now as the bottom four billion and kind
of instability occurring from that of
course Pinker is right overall we've
gotten a lot better a society but
there's never been this stratification
well so never is a long time and the the
if you look at people there's six
billion more extra people
that here now that weren't here 100
years ago and that be the driving hidden
factor in this is is breeding in
population that of course when you you
know 7x the time the number of
individuals it will put strains on the
ecosystem and and it'll exacerbate
certain things like inequality that it's
not so much that subsistence level
people are worse than they were a
hundred years ago it's just that the
ultra-wealthy
people now can exist that couldn't have
even existed 100 years ago there were no
private plans or yachts or you know that
kind of thing a hundred years ago and
and so the the really pressing force on
this is the population growth and there
is driven largely by individual people
be being seen as a farming resource a
labor resource or a warring resource and
that the like the survival strategy that
was useful in in the past was to use
human labor to generate wealth and now
technology can generate wealth without
the human labor so breeding more people
isn't necessarily better it's actually a
burden and so the places where people
are better educated where especially
where women are better educated the
population growth is is now flat or
negative and the places that are still
subsistence farming agrarian type things
that the population growth is still very
strong
and so that as long as that continues
there will be disparity in wealth but it
doesn't mean that the bottom tier of of
the world society is being pushed down
that there there also life comfort is
coming up it is - it is but
their life comfort is coming up at this
rate and the in the if and in
socioeconomic status there's is coming
up at this rate
yeah well that so this may be a
speciation event we're talking about
there's like plants and animals and and
the plants might be jealous of animals
because they can move and the animals
might be jealous of the plants because
they know they they have a more
comfortable life with with less you know
need for hunting so there are advantages
and disadvantages but they become
different species and so it may be that
the technologically empowered humans
will become a different species from for
example the religious fundamentalists
those that are not technologically
empowered well or choose not to be some
things that they couldn't be but they
some will choose not some will not be
able to afford to well so afford to
implies that there's a investment of
capital in people to enable them to grow
in wealth that they're there are many
examples of the wealthiest people in the
world who started out with almost no
resources and some and absolutely so
it's totally very especially in
economies like Africa are coming up that
there's so many potentials for new
billionaires to be made now with a
technology like an an iPhone that once
you have enough money to get a
smartphone or a laptop to connect you to
the internet then fat then sends you up
on a growth curve like that similarly to
once you get the technical once you get
the monetary amount to be able to afford
something like maybe augmented reality
or a neural lace or whatever it may be
that you can then go exponentially
increases well there are gonna be people
that choose not to all that stuff so do
you do you think that there will be then
a speciation in terms of people that are
technology equipped and well I think
there's both speciation and recombining
happening all the time and what
we're species become distinctly separate
meaning they can't breed with each other
any longer that's usually because
they're occupying different niches yeah
and they've become specialized to that
niche that and so an example is maybe
the Amish becoming you know or focus it
not becoming but focusing on sort of
agricultural technology avoidance
lifestyle yeah and where the the super
techno dependent people who need
artificial insemination and c-sections
to breed and and that they they can't
even breed biologically together they
must have technology to just reproduce
and that those people eventually may not
even be able to breed with the you know
regular agrarian type of people and then
you have two species there's sort of the
techno people and the the anti techno
people okay so we are looking like we're
moving into the conversation about the
the merging of the different
conversations that we're having and the
different technologies that were
developing so what is what is the
process looking like for us to achieve
the singularity because there's a
difference between a singularity and the
singularity a singularity is the black
hole in the center of a galaxy the
singularity is the merging of humans and
technology to a point of such
[Music]
sophistication that there is
Nutan you take it over well so the
singularity is the term that comes from
physics and and it was originally coined
to describe the event horizon around a
mathematical point where things fall out
of the model and that became to be known
as the the singularity is the event
horizon where you fall into a black hole
in cosmology in his face and that turned
out to be predicted by Einstein's field
equations and and observed in in
cosmology and astronomy looking for
central points of of gravity in a sense
and and that that are black holes and so
the term basically means change into
unpredictability and they the term was
repurposed in in the 90s of in science
fiction and then later in reycarts Wiles
book called the singularity is near to
describe the evolution of Technology and
the technology becoming more complicated
and more sophisticated and that enabling
new kinds of things like the arising of
intelligence in machines most notably
the internet and so if the the way Ray
would describe this technological signal
singularity would be the time at which
the Internet becomes smarter than people
or collective humanity of people and in
the the hundred year trend of computers
and machines in the internet becoming
smarter and smarter it has been tracking
for a hundred years in this exponential
path and if you just forecast that a
little bit further into 2029 or 2045
the internet will most likely be smarter
than all people combined yes and that's
and what happens when that happens is
unpredictable and that's a lot of what
can be said about that and it may be
good it may be bad and that's probably a
function of perspective and that it kind
of loops as to what we were talking
about with technology that there is the
potential for it to be very very good
like fire or the potential for it to be
very very bad yeah or somewhere in
between like like people are able to
remember things and they're able to
learn and know things and and so Google
is really good at learning and knowing
things better than any person yep and so
the the fact that you can ask Google for
anything and it generally has a correct
answer is already way better than people
yep and it hasn't necessarily hurt
society or people you know maybe
librarians or or something that much and
so that's a knowledge singularity as
opposed to an intelligent singularity
where the the capability of the machines
as as exceeded people already already
knowledge singularity has already
occurred yeah okay and and so the like
how do you process that knowledge which
might be intelligence is already pretty
good and getting better on this
exponential pace as rade describes in
his book that forecasting it forward it
it will get better much faster than our
intuition would have us think and so the
ability of the technology to learn for
example is it's accelerating in its
capability where it's not just a little
better each year as a person might be
it's twice as good each year and
and that has a compounding effect in
that you know when you go from two to
four well that's not so noticeable but
when you go from four to eight or eight
to sixteen then it starts you've gone
from 2 to 16 in a short time and so
that's where things people are taken by
surprise if well how did this get so
good so fast I didn't really feel that
coming instinctually so what what about
the intelligence singularity well that
would be the intelligence is you know
playing go playing chess like recently a
test stanford of how how accurately you
can read Wikipedia and report
information on it
the software is has beat humans oh yeah
in the last few months I mean you just
go and shake someone's hand in an event
and they're like hi my name is Paul and
then all of a sudden you don't even
listen to their name let alone when you
read an article how much do you actually
retain the yeah so the intelligence
singularity is already occurring with
yeah with go and with chess and with
even being able to beat out more cause
or drive the car or fly plane or trade
stocks or exactly be a lawyer there's a
lot of things that that an AI systems
are able to do better than humans okay
so then that becomes an intelligence
singularity in go or in flying a plane
or in trading a stock so there's
intelligence singularities in these
different domains
mm-hm but now what is the grand
intelligence well so you could say how
smart is the Internet okay and okay and
is the Internet conscious yeah and so
you know that definition of a
distributed set of subsystems that have
a consensus opinion well that is a kind
of form of consciousness and that the
Internet likely already has that but the
internet isn't just electronic there's
there's like three billion people in the
internet and so the complexity of the
Internet is three billion times more
than the complexity of any one person
already and plus you add the the
information storage and the processing
and support to it so you're saying we're
already in intelligence singularity yeah
it's it's a hybrid system combined of
biological components and an electronic
component and the biological components
are us and our minds and what we've put
into the internet and then the
electronic but it's also the real-time
processing power in you know where you
can ask a question to the Internet and
the answer might come back from Google
but it might come back from a person so
this is this is amazing I'm really
excited to have you back in the future
and to unpack this more there's so much
to unpack here and it's so exciting all
these different singularities across
domains that have already been achieved
this internet singularity that is
already has all these different minds
that have been been uploading
information to it and there's only gonna
be the other three billion minds that
are about to upload their information to
it and then there's gonna be all the
artificial intelligence algorithms that
are put into a place to be able to parse
the data to make sense of it and to
learn about me better than I know me oh
so there's absolutely so many great
conversations past that we'll take this
down couple last thoughts are do you
believe we are alone in the cosmos so
that this is the Fermi paradox and and a
variation of it that I like called the
transaction hypothesis which is if life
is naturally occurring complexity
and it's it should evolve in other
planets or other places doesn't
necessarily need a planet that by common
sense that if it evolved here is should
evolve somewhere else and in the Fermi
paradox is well if that's the case well
why don't we see it and or cease simple
you know some traces of it and that
partly that's we haven't looked hard
enough or long enough and so it may just
be a matter of time until we find
evidence of it and they the other part
of that is that as as we are evolving to
be a more complex planet and a more
complex species will be also becoming
more energy efficient and more intricate
and so the chips and phones and the
fiber-optic network and and so forth
from outer space is becoming quieter and
more invisible as it becomes more
complex and faster and more
sophisticated and so we've evolved in a
sort of disequilibrium where we're
blasting TV and radio out into space and
sending rockets here and there and all
that kind of thing and so it's a
disequilibrium where we're spewing a lot
of stuff out into space and so people
far away we'd be able to see it but as
we evolved to be more more complicated
and more intricate will also be quieter
and more efficient and more difficult to
discover
and so the transection hypothesis is
that advanced life forms on other
planets or in other places that are more
sophisticated than we are have already
gone to a much more efficient way of
being that maybe much more advanced than
and complicated than we are and and thus
there we just can't see them cloaking
well not necessarily cloaking but not
being know uh not being noticeable cover
yeah
yeah so okay so the with this sheer
amount of life and that that is
potentially orbiting other stars and
with the shimmer of potential of their
evolutionary capabilities they very
likely have figured out ways to become
less discoverable by advancing their
technologies well their motivation isn't
to be less discoverable it's just a
waste less to waste less and that's what
we're doing right now is we're figuring
out how to waste less yeah well good
okay and then last question is are we in
a computer simulation well this is kind
of a question of a different question
about what is God in that we touched on
you know as an infinite we have a mother
who is an all-powerful all-knowing you
know wise and strong being that takes
care of us and and all of our life and
so every person has a longing for their
infancy and the kind of freedom that
that gives and so as we mature and and
through puberty and hormones say we'll
separate from your mother the people
still have a longing for that feeling
and and two-thirds of people in the
world say well there's a god that has
basically the same characteristic so
knowing all powerful being and so that
that both created our life and our world
and runs it and so this concept of a
simulation is as like saying well there
is some God who wrote the simulation and
were and there they have a plan and
we're just players in it and that's a
way that we rationalize and and
you know say well well we're just in a
simulation and and that that's something
that is saying well this the person who
wrote the simulation is God and so the
question is okay well are they in a
simulation or or what is the motivation
of the simulation and and so in my
opinion were not in a simulation we're
in you know a universe that has certain
characteristics but I I think it's a
distributed decentralized system and
that there isn't a command and control
center there isn't an all-powerful being
and that would be this God who wrote the
simulation yeah that we're in yeah I
love thinking about it as the greatest
experiment ever being able to tweak all
the different variables the proximity to
the star the brightness of the star the
mass of the planet how many beings
evolved when they evolved its edge are
all that good stuff is super interesting
to be able to analyze and see okay so
you're you're on the side of no yeah
there's another take on that it is that
like mathematical models that try and
simulate you know how a flower grows or
how the climate works on a planet or are
designed using a language of mathematics
that is sort of internally consistent
but limited in its capability and so
there's in it there's a saying in
mathematical modeling which is some of
my background that that all the models
are wrong in that like your model is
incomplete and that you design it to to
simulate something that you observe but
there's there's maybe some
characteristics of how this flower grew
that I didn't know about and they're not
in the model and so the model isn't the
flower and the sort of like saying the
map of a territory is not the territory
or the menu is not the food
and that the simulation is not the
reality it's a lesser than version of
the reality Oh interesting okay so this
is so the simulation itself is is not as
it's a lesser version of what we
experienced in this reality yeah and and
if we could understand all of the
aspects of physics and chemistry and and
and so forth then we might be able to
make more accurate models but we don't
understand yeah Rhys what do you think's
the most beautiful thing in the world I
would say ecosystems like like life that
we're both part of and dependent on yeah
exactly and that's a that's a really
great way to loop it all the way back to
what you were teaching us at the
beginning ecosystems are a very very
beautiful and profound thing to be able
to both understand and immerse yourself
in but also to be able to go out go
outside of what you know about them and
go and learn more and so that's kind of
the 99% and the 1% again the control the
free-willed
the conscious ability that we have and
then just our analysis understanding of
being a node in the 99% of the network
functionality of society across
economics and politics and mimetics and
cultural systems and even biology of
considering they're eating a banana what
actually goes into that from the last
day in the last couple minutes and even
the last millisecond beforehand or the
last million years beforehand and the
perspective from your perspective versus
someone else perspective so this is this
is amazing Rana oh what do you what do
you think any any thoughts yeah as a
matter of fact you schedule a little
appointment for three o'clock yeah we
should go to a Lisa not right away yes
we should get a photo of
of reefs for our upcoming yeah book that
we're gonna we're working on so we have
we have a simulation book that we're
working on where we're gonna take
pictures beautiful pictures of our
guests will release some more
information on that soon we hope to use
it as a piece to inspire people as they
flip through and look through all these
diverse people in what they're building
yeah she left okay yeah that's okay
that's okay we'll figure out how to
we'll figure out how to solve it so yeah
that ended up being a longer session
then then we plan but it was very
powerful very good I really appreciated
having you Thank You Reese thank you
well put some links in the bio as well
Reese are you Reese underscore Jones on
Twitter well I don't care for Twitter
that must be I'm Reese underscore Jones
on Twitter resented her or well we also
have Reese's LinkedIn profile as well he
hasn't really I actually really like
Reese's banner it's brain mass the body
mass ratios and I how humans are just up
in the top corner it's this is these are
the things that drew me to Therese and
is just Polymathic understanding the
worlds so guys if you had a good time if
you thought that this was useful content
for you please give us a like comment
subscribe share it with other people
find us on patreon we're currently
giving away exclusive content we're
giving access to live events guest QA
all this stuff so join us on patreon
shoutouts around Vargas for our director
and producer doing an amazing job behind
the camera system and that is it will
catch you guys again soon thanks for
tuning in and on the way out we give you
these nope we'll give you the claw
Murch coming soon do you believe we're
in a computer simulation whoa
see you soon go ahead talk
[Music]
[Music]